one of the most important things when
athletes is that the plain surface be
comfortable safe good footing if it's
too hard it's abrasive and it could be
detrimental to the athlete and if it was
too soft it's tiring to run on it has to
be just the right mix
I'm John Provo I'm the proud inventer of
fielder as a jock and out of love of
sport I got into the artificial turf
business trying to do something to
benefit athletes the beginning of the
turf business the astroturf product was
a most everywhere astroturf was a very
abrasive surface if you slid on it you
could easily share some skin off and if
you fell on it a concussion was more
likely if you hit the wrong way
we did a lot of testing I don't know how
many different types of recipes
different types of densities of turf
different pile heights if you put too
much rubber it's too soft you put too
much sand it's too hard and if you don't
do right it's not the same plain surface
from that concept I did my first soccer
field players loved it was great however
that soccer field wore out in the first
season and so we changed the fibers the
turf that made a huge difference because
it didn't shred like the original did
lab tests showed that by having sand on
the bottom the mixture of sand and
rubber in the middle and rubber on top
it gave the best shock absorbency and
performance characteristics
the three layer system we created to
give us a certain feel similar to
natural grass when we got that that was
an aha moment it's one of the biggest
challenges was to get people to believe
in football played on field turf and
Nebraska coach Tom Osborne was
introduced to the concept and he flew to
Maryland to see my partner John Gillman
to inspect the field coach Osborne gets
to the field walks across the field and
he says so where is this field that
you're talking to us about and John says
you just walked across the field now
that was a moment in history because
coach Osborne was suitably impressed and
that was the revelation that we're going
into some area that's really going to
change the world after we installed in
Nebraska field then the game was on
national television since when shooting
upward almost instantly business grew by
leaps and bounds
when you first walk on a filter field
you can feel the cushioning that's
subtle when you play on it you know that
you're playing on a field that is much
safer than anything they played on
before including natural grass we really
never dreamed of that it would be this
big and I'm thrilled that the guy from
Montreal could develop something like
this that had an impact
you